welcome to this video I'm playing sorry
deal suddenly deal or from the US and we
got a French defense hmm yeah let's play
the Queen d5 line recently recommended
in a book I don't really know it too
well i hope this son this still works
out okay he played the short castle at
least okay well i wasn't even aware that
this is a move interesting
and yeah well they play Knight f6 very
often hmm ok let's go here keep the deep
bone protected not sure that I want to
return it immediately ok it's another
move of the queen but after Bishop e7 96
the night only Freud's also yeah asked a
serious question while Knight f6 is not
really helping with my development I'd
like to play Bishop e7 first we should
be 79 f 6 so that after Knight f6 I can
actually be captioned ok he really wants
to get it back in and I could play just
better d 7 yeah why not 94th losing
material so he probably needs to take on
c6 movie doesn't ok let's let's get
pieces out not think about how to maybe
keep this bond it's a it's not so
important to keep it
okay I really should be should be
alright in this position chief I've
didn't come maybe five push-ups e6
Bishop c6 the taxi form so this may be
was an option okay yeah let's simplify
okay he needs to take on this heaven
make sure what he's doing with the
bishop is to stay on b5 okay well Bishop
e7 is there an intermediate move like
some crazy stuff Knight takes Knight xe2
looks really really wacky job maybe
night see to Knight f6 Bishop a6 Bishop
of six another side don't do now thats
let's not that's this is really really
crazy that's a play the normal move yeah
I don't think Nazi to really work they
can check that after the game briefly
with the comp but it didn't it didn't
look right to me yeah now probably just
Queen takes deform and it's about equal
yes yeah probably there's nothing better
than to exchange Queen cm and the
question is what to do now is there some
way to play this I mean to be able to be
a bit officious here I try this try b5
try to play against the C porn with rook
c8
you can take twice on f6 if you want
check it sir it's a very draws
positional that's clear hmm not sure
about a 4 i'd say it's hmm don't know i
mean yeah this is probably necessary and
otherwise I'll go and I go way five
myself so let's go here I take the C
porn yeah I know he's got count to play
against against the bball okay let's see
can I can I activate the King here let's
try that maybe f5 and King King up to
see five even yeah let's let's try that
okay if I go King c5 now my place III
hmm it might play look he fought so
attacking the pawn okay let's prevent
that for a moment yeah Yello the system
still there still some play left in this
position it's not entirely dead okay
does he want to go to to d3 checking or
check the edge Paul not sure okay what
what I'm sure if I need to play a bit
quicker ok so let's go for some
counterplay check and okay if he takes
you can take here and I could cover the
porn and some very modest smooth going
to have an idea
maybe I can provoke he can take edge
services better but now I strokous
offside let's see maybe I can do
something against that this is saying
and I'm King c5 is going ok form so
thats that's too bad
hi
now this was simply bad plane and far
too slow but on top of that yeah I tried
to do something here maybe this wasn't
called for don't really know they must
be cautious if it takes f7 i'm giving a
check and rookie one this is this is
very very tricky time watching them I
think I'm just winning now this is made
how does he prevent that see pawn moves
whoopty to mate and this is just check
made yeah there were they had no way to
prevent it check check
check check yeah of course playing on
time I'm very done on time nine seconds
in the digital didn't find them made
check check check check check check mate
John 3071 hundreds of a second this is
enough of a chick made this was a bit
lucky and I really I really lost the
threat he and the scent game trying to
try to do something I mean black is
somewhat more comfortable here because
of the sea porn but not really sure
maybe around here should be really ok
but here here it's probably too
ambitious what I'm doing I mean I can I
can play a rook c8 and giving giving
lots of checks let's say this one ok
here in this position I actually and you
probably need to play something
something conservative like rocky fire
for example now this was too much ok
here this is nonsense and maybe I can
play it but here this is just better
going to e to something like that it's
enough pressure I've got this and I'm
threatening to get all the pawns this is
probably
enough for a draw okay around here hmm
maybe silky 5 and this is this is not go
down not good what he needs to he needs
to react to the strata simply ignored it
I move like okay for or something like
that this is just losing can probably I
haven't made our I didn't I didn't I
didn't find it check check yeah yeah I
should of course take with the with the
rook much better check then okay five
this is much easier to play and I
thought okay let's get a get a quick
quick passer but cats it takes channels
number of moves to actually win know
what thanks for watching